In this section we continue our hands-on exercise with the next steps of the Mesh to MetaHuman workflow.
So let's dive back into Unreal Engine.
Now the next step is to adjust the camera in lighting.
Go here and click on the viewport camera.
Change the field of view to 20 degrees or something less.
And now position the camera so that the scan is facing forward and is completely visible.
Take your time when framing the face.
Now with the camera positioned, the next step is to adjust the lighting.
Go to the top left of the viewport toolbar and click on lit.
Here you can choose from lit, unlit, or lighting only.
For meshes with skins textured with the skins albedo, unlit works best.
For other meshes, you can rotate the light by holding down L until the entire face is evenly lit.
It is worth mentioning that lighting and framing can influence the way in which the tracking markers track the facial features.
With a full view of the face, the next step is to create a neutral pose frame.
Select the neutral pose component.
In the main toolbar, select promote frame.
A pop-up will appear saying that the current promoted frame will be set as the front view.
If you wish to add additional frames, you can add them by clicking on this.
Just ensure by going to the neutral pose detail panel under frame promotion that used to solve is enabled only for the neutral front facing frame.
Before we continue, let's review the steps we just completed.
After creating a metahuman identity asset and populating it, the next step is to adjust the viewport lighting and camera positioning.
As this step can influence the way the tracking markers land on the facial features.
Adjust the lighting by going to the viewport toolbar and selecting lit.
Then, choose between lit, unlit or lighting only.
As mentioned earlier, for meshes with skins textured using the Skinz Albedo, unlit works best.
For the other two lighting options, rotate the light until the face is evenly lit.
There will be variation in the way tracking markers are placed on the facial features with different lighting scenarios.
And you may find one setting may give you better tracker positioning than others depending on your mesh.
For framing in the viewport toolbar, use the viewport camera options to change the field of view to something around 20 degrees or less.
And then position the camera so that the eyes, mouth and nasolabial folds are visible.
The next step is to promote a front-facing frame.
Select the neutral pose component and then in the main toolbar select promote frame.
Additional frames can be helpful for features such as the ears if you wish to track more details.
When using multiple frames in the neutral pose details panel under the frame promotion settings,
ensure that use to solve is enabled only for the front-facing frame.
Now, let's continue with the next steps of this workflow.
The next step is to track the neutral pose.
With the neutral frame selected, go to the main toolbar and select track markers.
Once we click this, we can see that the tracking markers have been placed on the facial features.
Something to note is that the albedo texture from the scan assists the tracking markers in locating and shaping facial features such as the eyebrows and nasolabial fold creases.
If we were to track this without a texture, it is possible we may get different results as the tracking markers may have a harder time locating the shape of the eyebrows for instance.
In the event that tracking markers may need to be adjusted, for instance, I may want to define the eyes a bit more.
You can select individual tracking markers and reposition them by clicking on them and moving them with your mouse.
If you wish to move an entire tracking section, double-click on the tracking marker curve.
This will select all of the tracking markers, allowing you to move these all together.
You can also deselect tracking markers by holding down shift and then clicking on each one individually.
If you want to add more definition to certain features, you might want to add new tracking markers.
Using the mouth area as an example, using the mouse wheel, I'm going to zoom in on the upper right lip.
To add additional tracking markers, press control and then left mouse click on the tracking curve.
I'm going to go and inspect the right eye and move some of these tracking markers to define the tear-duck region a bit more.
And now I'm going to move over to the left eye and do the same by moving some of these tracking markers in order to fine-tune their position over here.
I'm going to zoom out using the mouse wheel and then with my mouse hovering over the mouth, I will zoom in.
Here, I want to add a bit more definition to the top of the upper lip area.
Again, spend some time with this process as this type of solve depends on how these tracking markers are placed on a 2D image,
as opposed to it being solved on the actual geometry.
Once you are happy with the position of the tracking markers, the next step is to run the metahuman identity solve and view the results.
Go to the toolbar and select metahuman identity solve.
Once the solve completes, you can toggle between the solved mesh and the template mesh in the viewport toolbar by clicking on the AMB tabs.
We can view the results side by side or we can view this as an overlay.
The overlay allows us to compare specific regions of the face close up and decide if we are happy with the way the facial features have been tracked.
If there are areas that may still need adjustments, you can continue the process of fine-tuning the positions of the tracking markers.
If you ever get an error after running the identity solve, you may find it helpful to simply move a few tracking markers and then rerun the identity solve.
Now before we continue, let's review the steps we just completed.
Once you have adjusted the framing and lighting and promoted a front-facing frame, the next step is to track a neutral pose.
You can adjust the tracking markers if needed to fit around the facial features.
Using your mouse, you can move individual markers or groups of markers by double-clicking on a track curve and then moving it.
You can deselect tracking markers by holding down shift and then clicking on individual tracking markers.
And you can add markers by pressing control and then left mouse click on a tracking curve.
Once finished repositioning the tracking markers, the next step is to run the metahuman identity solve.
Inspect the results by using the AMB tabs in the viewport toolbar.
You can view the results side by side between the solved mesh and the template mesh or by using the overlay option.
Now let's continue with the next steps of this workflow.
That's it for this section.
In the next video, we continue our hands-on exercise with the final steps of the mesh-to-metahuman workflow.